tá taboado diz pessoal de quem fala é o
dark seja muito em mim jamais um vídeo
desde já muito obrigada que nem viu
coisas pra cá subsolo de 1500 cartas tem
momentos em blogs gigantes tipo não sei
o que está aqui dentro do super ansioso
por abrir mas pra quem quiser enviar
mais coisas vai por ser aquilo na minha
caixa postal processo a enviarem depois
abro em vídeo não sei ao certo como é
que se faz chamar esta série mas já ter
sido uma coisa tipo e as caixas não as
cartas do bar não esta também não tem
sido mais chamativo a caixa postal não
estamos impondo um y alguns comentários
como é que tem que se chama esta série
de vídeos a abrir as coisas vocês mandam
a minha câmera está a torta
vocês são todos os porcos têm como
amanhã vamos lá ver as cartas
a primeira que eu tenho aqui é do andré
e nasce o o que é isto já vi que uma
coisa ou não podem enfiar uma casa
vizinha que ouviu jato de choque do pt
perguntou quem é um wiki já posso vencer
dois torneios de ficar rico e deixar o
youtube e já escreveu enviou também um
pneu dianteiro
assim vai ficar toda sexy para as
meninas eu tenho medo inteiríssimo isto
tem um funk picos e hospitalares na teta
eu simplesmente morro
o dedo filha
eu vou morrer e isso não dá pra entender
meu em um piso estragado ou ladário que
eu gosto muito dos seus vídeos do que
você faz o meu nome em treinar cilso
português com um olho e eu adoro o
trabalho que faz com o pc pode dar gosto
dos três vídeos e um trabalho que faz
com o pc amplo que o tupi se julga ter
fugido disse na sessão semanal do canadá
só que aí tens algum animal se tens
mostra a vocês querem nenhuma nem marlon
é o desenho é obrigado inácio e vamos
pra próxima
na próxima quarta e dali se ela enviou
esta [ __ ] não me envolvo preto eu estou
uma carta do nome de uma bruxa dentro
das curvas ou uma carta sua turma e órfã
em virtude de seus vídeos e não cansei
junho e outubro preferido foi por tua
causa que eu comecei a gostar de fábio
neves e fred
quanto à inspiração do siri tornar o
youtube
adoro beijinhos e luís monteiro a
próxima quarta e do antônio não antónio
rousseau e wall e não não existem muita
coisa querendo inspecções um banho
porque focava não conseguir o estudo
muito design o que é isso meu deus o
mundo vai acabar muito mais poder
supostamente distribuiu como caloura e
como atingir o pokémon fez um solo foxy
na sua carne estragada aqui tentar matar
o pessoal todo o critério fosse going
out tonight o beijo mês do ramadã em um
prazo de um mês
frannie em primeiro lugar parabéns 21
quando ficar velho já começa mal o dia
em que conheci foi muito fácil de 2 foi
o melhor de sempre foi algo pra era
obrigado eu falo pelo design estão
simplesmente portais se quiser mandar
mais porque o osso próxima carta a
próxima quarta da lista é o chandra
silva eu não sei se iria apontar a
câmera mas por baixo pra vocês verem as
coisas mas acho que citavam citroen
venceu isto lemes da ostentação eu não
sei como é que consegue pintar isto com
este brilhante 2001 e suja não deixe de
ler esta carta é daquelas foi um destes
gigantescos por isso vamos ter aqui para
depois goleiro
depois porque se não vira e fica grande
pois as pessoas vão ver e é isso
obrigado ao estilo dano e wilma
aproximam já deu pra ver que eu tomei
café é agora abrir um pacote este
arrastão cão eu não tenho uma aqui
discutir realmente é um curso online
kraft o que não pode ser outro um design
pelo que é isto
meu deus kraft sem eu adoro minecraft
quem viu este pacote foi o daniel
delgado quer lhe estás bem estar às
pressas firme não estudou bravos não não
vamos abrir o nosso carinho mas nunca lá
o futebol é o pólo aqui dentro - vocês
são brutais nem trabalhá-los daniel
conquistou bar mil até já tirar da
cabeça porto enviaram uma coisa de 6 foi
quem eu hoje não é preciso gastar tanto
dinheiro mas afinal era troca entre
ficar com o brinquedo em gasto na caixa
primeira carta eu quero ter o design é
um desenho e do funk noite fred sou eu
exposto à mente o dn ainda arranjar
outra luz por este vírus porque esta
luta é uma bosta e começar a brilhar e
vocês não vêem nada é oque tem aqui
dentro o ato sexual um grande feito por
mim em goiânia mas com o sentimento das
duas
muitos beijinhos muitas vezes 28 minimal
e muitos parabéns acreditar que o design
pessoal eu vou ler esta carta depois
porque está gigante mas obrigado enem
iria 3 pelas nossas criancinhas ou seja
sabem como o juiz explica que caiu o
stock car também do brasil eduardo quer
ser o meu deus meu fc o meu fã-clube do
twitter enviam uma faca em carta meu
espaço enviado brasil tem louvar quatro
selos 46 deve ser no seu palco móvel o
seu povo iam uns eu falar agora que o
seu buscar até minha casa é onde ainda
sentir um cheiro rosa de vida aqui
dentro
o primeiro é que isto uo isto tá muito
bom o regime está em outro desafio
fascinante 7 fred sair para o banho que
eu tenho aqui uma coroa de flores sob a
imagem mas sim na grota alguém diria tá
velhinho mas mais continuar a não espera
seria um brasileiro mas continua com
essa beleza toda parece que está fazendo
está fazendo
não percebo mais opta na frente o papa
com agora quero te desejar um feliz
aniversário e tudo de bom pra ti e que
fosse sempre seja essa pessoa
maravilhosa que tu é que tem muito
orgulho em você rouba dark fc e pessoal
sigam e isto me eo fc no twitter é
roubar kiev seqüestro estupro só porque
ela fazia em estúdio engraçado e também
por isso é escrito ilha esta carta do
pedro mendes pedro - o que domingo e as
plaquinhas safado que domingas o gato
pedro mendes nem tudo saiu pra [ __ ]
em todas as linhas pai carlos de
carvalho eu vejo este design
sou eu é ostentar é a beleza do nosso me
fred eu vou pendurar este evento todos
os designers que deixam bonfanti pra
[ __ ] eu vou ter isso aqui traz nenhum
tipo de campeonato aqui assim eu vou
bater um apoio estaleiro está ruindo
pedro tu és maior tu faz mais sentido
para mim eu quero quero saber mais
coisas duas porque estava o talão é
vamos passar à próxima desta carta de
cristiane novikov era um ato isolado a
rússia alguém abre só de 22 de março e
22 também cinco de miami quando bens
espero que este seja o melhor
aniversário vejam que o design que ela
fez pessoal de espera da indy aqui com
os links governos em baixo alcançado um
entrudo josé rosendo da silva é e região
também que parece tornar um partido com
molho de origem simples não é obrigado
leandro pelo design está muito bem visto
na minha boca toque o olho e também está
torto andar e espero que continue a
fazer os seus vídeos radicais e
libertino já faz filho de caetano faz
videochamadas bicicleta que o atacante
sofre quem fala é o braço leonardo josé
era tudo um leonardo o leandro
não é o leandro que tem dois nomes têm
sido opção mandato vai o psicólogo ter
isso talvez leandro leonardo não sai
muito obrigado entrou pelo catuaí vamos
patrocinar a cutucar os meninos dos hoje
já que muita coisa dentro mesmo o
técnico - as mangas mas teve marcelo já
ganhei uma carta em bbb um filme é um
filme
eu não sei o quê show que enviaram um
dvd carros
vamos ver o resto a partir de uma
caixinha que supostamente já sobre o
neco e chocolate e enviaram um ferro na
china
o livro tem aqui uma de também cristo é
agenda 2015 já posso fazer mais vídeos
porque agora vou organizar tudo nessa
agenda de jogos foi que não os jogos
desvendar que acostou mundo não consegui
nada
o que é isto
como as camas eram muitas formas roupas
mais umas mais gomas
mas gomes mas o meu isto não acaba em
seu país como o lar como não leve triste
tem 12 anos vivem em lisboa e isso é uma
grande fã toalha e escrevi isto para te
desejar o melhor dia sempre muitos
beijinhos parabéns d'arc 3 mil textos
sabe que eu tenho e é também já que o
estudo é louca que vai fazer na minha
vida eu vi o pessoal vamos ficar por
aqui como estive muito obrigado por tudo
muito obrigado pelas coisas que vocês me
enviaram está mesmo muito importante
para mim receber esse carinho todo em
minha casa com a seleção do [ __ ] você
só mostra o mais próximo que eu ainda
caso pessoal vai estar na descrição vai
perceber que também mantém mais coisas
vou tentar fazer que um vídeo deste mês
a mês ainda tenho que fazer perguntas e
respostas mas é isso quando o nosso
punho leque de favoritos estão brutais e
vamos embora